the difference between an invention and
innovation
is that invention is something new
is making something real and
economic out of this invention
[Music]
thank you for joining me for coming to
20 minute leaders how are you thank you
very much for having me i'm i'm fine
thank you wonderful i'm extremely
excited to have you
er talking about corporate innovation
you're
part of a group called orbia 22 000
people
yet you're tasked with possibly one of
the most difficult jobs there
how do you take an organization of tens
of thousands of people
and bring innovation whether it's bottom
up top down
i've had the privilege of being both at
large organizations
like 8200 which is a large organization
but also part of a startup like hippo
which is 200 people
but shy before that you have to tell me
how you started by creating a board game
how
what's that about okay
so it was after my army service you know
and during the army service you feel uh
you feel empowered you feel important
and you feel great and then and then
you finish the army service i was in a
in a combat unit
and and basically no one no one
recognizes you for whatever you did so
when you look for jobs you start getting
all kind of like lousy jobs
uh so i started one of these lousy jobs
and and i was pretty bored
um and it and it happened that it was
the 50th anniversary of israel
um and a friend of mine and i with we
said this is
this must be this must be a very very
good business opportunity
so we started we started thinking okay
what what how can we make a business out
of this like
big event in the history of israel you
know 50 years of israel
and you know to to make a long story
short we screened a few ideas but we
came up with with this
idea that people don't know or kids do
not know the history of israel
right so if we can if we can teach them
in a very fun way
the basics about the history of israel
you know the leaders the peace agreement
the wars the sporting events
that would be great so this is what we
did
and uh i love that
i love that because like a lot of other
kids i grew up
not really learning the history of
israel when i was about to go to
an officer's academy to bodhisatt i got
a book that was this thick
that i had to now within about 24 hours
memorize the whole thing
and i wish i had a game like that when i
was when i was just starting out
but walk me through your journey from
there because you've done quite a few
fascinating things
leading up to corporate innovation a lot
of them are really tangled you have
mckinsey in there you haven't
the fema in there talk to me a little
bit about about your process up to today
yeah so i think i think the the funny
thing is that now looking
20 years back there is kind of like a
red a line a thread that's connecting
all these things but
when i was doing each one of these it
didn't seem like there is a
there is a story so right as as i said
my my my first real business experience
was this
startup company uh that developed the
the board game for the kids and then i
said okay i need to get a technology
education so i went to do a computer
science degree
in the iedc um and i was very very
fortunate
to be accepted to the zell program
in the idc yeah yeah and this was this
was the first year
of the zell program right the very first
year
wait yeah so you went you were in it
with a saf
yes this is how i know i suffered well
this is how you know i stuff my boss
amazing okay exactly exactly and we were
actually
in a in a very small study group where
we did a consulting project to a big
company in israel and we we became good
friends and
yeah this is how i know ourselves now
things are coming together he also went
to mckinsey okay
great wonderful yeah so what happens
after
so i did zell and and what i understood
that i love technology but i like the
business side of technology
i i i couldn't program like it was i got
bored
right so then then i worked for a few
startup companies
mainly in business development and and
marketing
so you could you could say that the
first you know eight
nine years were kind of like an
entrepreneurial type of experience
either my own startup or other people's
startups
and then and then in 2007
i said okay i want i want to jump to the
to the to the adult pool you know the
the big boys pool
um and by the way that that's another
maybe assaf even doesn't know about it
but when we were in zell
he was starting to talk about you know
doing an mba
in stanford and in chicago and and i
said
really i i it never even crossed my mind
but then i said okay
if he talks about it it makes sense let
me dig into that
so i dug into that a few years later and
i understood that i i want to do it and
i can do it
uh so i went to do my mba at insead
which was a great experience and then i
said okay this was this was nice but
the real the real business school of the
world is
is consulting so i joined mckenzie
uh and i did that for a few years in
london and in israel
wow and then in 2012 there was a very
interesting opportunity to join netafem
netafim is an israeli-born company and
today is the largest
irrigation company in the world you know
probably some people know about it
and i did that i had no idea i i knew it
was a miracle it's one of israel's early
miracles
but i wasn't aware that it's the biggest
irrigation company in the world
it is it's now more than billion dollar
in revenue
and it's the largest irrigation or
irrigation company in the world
yeah wow and and do you mind sharing
just in towards the back story of
netaphim
why it was innovation through a
necessity because i get i get so
inspired
every time i i understand that why why
it even happened
it happened again like you said out of
necessity so people were looking
to you know grow stuff in the desert
in the desert because we had to
yeah because you know a big chunk of
israel land is a desert
and and people people were sent to
inhabited the desert
so the the nether nerfin was founded by
one of the kibbutz
in israel okay because they needed
they needed a way to cultivate the
desert
and they needed a a a job for the
elderly
that couldn't go work outside but they
needed to do something
indoor right right so they partner they
partner with an engineer who came up
with the original
drip concept and they launched netafam
and
you know 60 something years later it is
the largest irrigation company in the
world
it it's it's remarkable to me to think
that we have an israeli company that is
60 something
years old but you're you're in at the
theme and you're working there really
with it with the leadership
how do you get enticed by this idea of
innovation
you because already netape is a big
organization but then you also
transition to orbia
and there you're literally you're tasked
with with leading innovation so how does
that how does that
come about okay so just to
to close the the story none of him i did
various positions the last one i was
managing the
the company product portfolio so we were
constantly thinking what is it that we
can
uh innovate right right um
and then billion dollar portfolio right
yes
yes and then you know
for me it was a a big a big
uh a combination of a couple of things
in in
early 2018 where when orbeez acquired
netapham
okay and orbia orbis is a very large
public company
a multinational seven billion dollar in
revenues
um so they acquired orbia and that of
him in 2018
and the other thing that happened in the
same very months
a new ceo came to orbia
a guy called daniel martinez and
he started a very very ambitious
transformation program
and he knew that innovation is a is a
significant pillar of that
transformation
so he was looking for someone to lead
the innovation activities in
inside orbia so he he pulled me out of
neda fame and
put me as part of the orbia management
team
and told me corporate innovation
go go build it um so before we continue
to talk about exactly what
what you did there when i hear the word
innovation a lot of people today they
hear innovation it's so it's a little
bit of a fluffy word
yes we innovate this it's like when a
startup says we revolutionize this
uh right what is innovation in its core
that this new ceo said i need a figure
that can come and help us
do it properly within orbia
right so there are multiple dimensions
to to their answers
to that answer i'll walk you like
briefly let me know if if you
if you want me to dig into any one of
these okay wonderful the first thing was
to define what is innovation right for
us
for us because innovation in a startup
is completely different than innovation
in a in a large multinational
right right so and and i spent
maybe the first six months doing a lot
of research
but what does it mean innovation in the
corporate world
and i met startups and vcs and
incubators and accelerators and academia
and i read thousands of books and
articles
and in order to be able to clarify what
what is it we want to do right
so the first thing was a was a
relatively simple definition that
everybody will understand
it it doesn't mean that it's perfect but
something that
you know everybody can connect to so
internally we define innovation
as creating something new
that addresses a need
and and this is the important part the
economic value that it will generate
is higher than the cost of developing it
right why is that important why is that
an important piece of of the
of the puzzle it's an important piece
because
you might know that 95 or so percent
of the global ip or patents that are
being created
are never commercialized right 95
percent yeah so the difference between
an invention
and innovation is that invention is
something new
innovation is making something real
and economic out of this invention right
i've never thought of it that way
so it's it's it's the in innovation is
different than
creativity it's different than invention
because as we said 95 of the invention
are never commercialized
not because they're not novel but
because there's no economic value
right right so this is this is how we
define it
and then the second step was to
understand
that innovation
is actually not a single term and there
are different types of innovation
right and you know your audience can
can read about it but i'll give you just
the one sentence
there is the are multiple frameworks to
think about the types of innovation but
the classic one that
people usually use is the difference
between
core adjacent and transformative
innovation
okay and and we don't need to spend more
a lot of time on that but just to
understand that there are
different levels of complexity in
innovation there are some things that
are closer to your current capabilities
the core
and there are innovation that relates to
new capabilities new customers new
markets that you want to
develop and this is more transformative
and then anything in between
and and and it is critical as an
organization not as a startup startup
can focus on on one specific
innovation right but as a corporate you
need to invest in all
of these three dimensions right right
so it's a it's it's it's an important
understanding so this was a
realization number two okay realization
number three
was about the fact that innovation again
in the context of a corporate world
is not an activity it's a portfolio
so if you think about you know you're an
engineer investor right
if you invest in one company you have 90
chances to fail
but you know if you're interested in 30
if you invest in 30
you have a certain probability that you
can out of the entire portfolio you'll
make a profit right
right and this is exactly the same way
to think about innovation it's a
portfolio
of activities some of them will fail
some of them will succeed but you want
to think about the entire
portfolio and that it progresses towards
the goals that you want to to achieve
right so this was
realization number three and realization
number four is about the time horizon
you want to invest in activities in that
portfolio some of them are short term
some of them are medium term and some of
them will pay out you know seven ten
years out
right so this is this is if you
if you want to kind of like the the
thing that i understood in the research
what are like
like the four principles if you wish
this is what what i understood in the in
the research and and
in the past two years we're trying to
implement all of that and building the
the the processes the infrastructure the
management
and all of that which which by the way
that's another important thing
many people think about innovation as
kind of like a a project
an initiative but but it's important to
understand that if you really want to be
successful in innovation
you have to think about it as a
corporate function
like finance like marketing like i.t
like r d you know
you have processes you have tenant
development
you have succession plans you have
budget you have
annual targets you know this is it's a
it's a corporate functionality
like any other function if you don't
manage it this way it will never succeed
right no i'm particularly
interested in what you were saying
before about that
innovation really to manage innovation
you're not managing a single project
because you're not
you will never invest in a single
company and say i'm putting all my eggs
in this basket
you manage a portfolio of innovative
solutions
that most of them will fail but you
expect that off the whole basket you'll
see some profit or some
or some greatness for the company and
and i keep thinking to all these
occurrences where i'm hearing about my
friends who may be going to their
to their managers or their bosses and
suggesting some innovative project
and the answer is always no because
this is not likely to succeed but and
and i can't help but
but wonder whether their managers are
thinking strategically about okay what
if we just take a pool of these
innovative projects if we can allow
ourselves to
and and then and then allow for the real
innovation to happen but chai
how do you actually tangibly go into an
organization that is 22 000 people
and encourage innovation because you
don't i'm guessing that you're not
hiring people to just to just
do innovative things you're trying to
encourage innovation internally within
the
core of the company right yeah
so i think what i'll share with you are
the
six current programs that we have under
the umbrella of corporate innovation and
this will
this will make it a little bit uh
clearer okay
first and foremost before before we talk
about the six programs
if the ceo and the senior leadership do
not think it's a top priority it will
never succeed
right and i'm fortunate to have a very
very
visionary future thinking and also a
very very
humble and truly great person as my ceo
right without that i could i could never
embark on on the journey
right um and also the entire management
of orbia
which by the way all of them other than
one are new
since the last two years right and
really international
um but within within the corporate
innovation so we have six programs one
we have
orbia ventures which is the corporate
venture capital
fund of orbia we have 130 million
dollars that we invest
in startups that are strategic to any
one of our five businesses
right wow then we have a startup
partnership
program where we want to take
you know pro products or services
developed by
startup companies and expand our
offering through a commercial
partnership
we have an advanced analytic program
which we started three months ago
to deploy advanced technologies like ai
and machine learning into the
activities that we do we have
a program called orbia lighthouse this
is actually
the official definition is a venture
studio again it's a new term
in innovation people can can dig it out
but innovation studio it's kind of like
an internal incubator like we
we launched new digital ventures or new
startups but everything is managed
internally
you know the budget the exploration the
er recruiting everything is
is internal right um
the fifth program is what we call
launchpad it's an internal innovation
program
where every person in the organization
can participate in innovation
and how do we coach them and how do we
train them and how we give them budget
to pilot
and we already have eight of those
project in in in in implement
implementation already
right so this launch pad is this
are these are these employees that can
come and say i have an idea that i want
to explore within orbia
so i want to take some time to explore
the city because obviously they have a
team that they're working for
so how how does it actually work because
this is where the
constraint is right they have their
daily job they have their kpis
that they have to meet yet they're
saying but i also want to spend some
time innovating
yeah so the way that it works
we don't carve out you know people out
of their day-to-day they need to do it
on top of the day-to-day
okay there is a recognition there is an
understanding and there is clarity
from the top management that once a
certain idea
move into what we call funded
experiments so we give them pilot and we
give them money to experiment
okay then they can spend you know 10 20
of their time on that but all the way
through you know
developing the idea asking what is the
problem
asking what could be the solution going
through the different stages of the
screening it's all on top of their
day-to-day job
right but we give them all the coaching
we teach them about lean startup
we bring people that can coach the guys
and help them succeed
um so but it's on top of their day job
it's not a it's not a carve out activity
okay okay
the last piece in the puzzle is a
circular economy
um it's a it's a it's a huge domain
and we can talk about it for hours but
basically it's how do we how do we
become
i mean orbia how can we become more
circular
how can we make profit but also
do it in a positive contribution to the
planet right
i love that i love that so so it sounds
like you're a venture capitalist you're
a startup advisor
you're you're you're helping drive the
company forward but you're also making
the world a better place
so uh should i expect that that
a lot of people are to be very jealous
after they listen to this talk about it
but this was extremely inspiring and
and i'm definitely taking a lot of
lessons moving forward to whatever
adventures i'll i'll start on my own
and but before we go shy i have to ask
you the most important question which is
three words
that you would use to describe yourself
yeah
okay it it it's funny because you know
in in the process and and
it came it kept me awake a little bit
last night you know the the question
because it's a good question
and i also asked my wife but what does
she think so if it's okay with you i'll
tell you what she said and i'll tell you
what i think okay
so i asked her okay three three words
that describe me so she said
ambitious a leader and high standards
well high standards it's two words but
okay um there's a hyphen and before
yeah and before i asked her i thought
you know what what what would i say
about myself and i said
curiosity perseverance and growth
i love that curiosity perseverance and
growth uh i think that all six words uh
match shine thank you very very much
this is just wonderful
and thank you for being on the show
thank you take care